police traffic stops in Ecuador largest
city Guayaquil are far from routine
these days armed officers wear
bulletproof vests and most have their
faces covered as they look for drugging
members that have been terrifying the
city
today they found a possibly legal gun in
this SUV
in January we arrested 145 people in
this neighborhood alone we found more
than 18 weapons short and large we want
people to feel safe
has become the epicenter of a Turf War
among National and international gangs
bombings and killings have become daily
occurrences as its Port has turned into
the main transport hub for cocaine
trafficking
Ecuador's Geographic position between
the world's two main cocaine producers
Peru and Colombia the use of U.S dollar
as currency and corruptible State
institutions made it ideal for the drug
cartels Ecuador used to be a safe
country in 2017 we had 5.6 homicides per
100 000 inhabitants now it's almost five
times that what it shows is that the
government didn't take the necessary
precautions yet we know cocaine
production had moved closer to our
borders and nothing was done in the most
vulnerable communities to prevent the
growth of the gangs
Fernando bastillas of a human rights
organization working in guaya kills
Forest neighborhoods confirms that the
social impact of drug trafficking has
been devastating after the covid-19
pandemic we saw organized crime gangs
becoming stronger and stronger at a time
of high unemployment they offered a way
to survive now Fear One fear to leave
your house to denounce to speak up
poverty and lack of opportunity have
made kids from neighborhoods like this
one on the outskirts of Guayaquil an
easy prey of criminal organizations bent
on turning them into the Canon fodder of
their turf wars
in response some residents have
organized a free football school to try
and keep kids away from The Lure of
using and dealing drugs
but the organizers tells us anonymously
for fear of retaliation that is not
enough
we had a recent case of a kid 15 years
old who fell for the money he was
offered you know they think it's the
best they can get he ended up killed
with 17 shots I felt the world collapsed
I knew him since he was eight it makes
you feel impotent
Akil